[Musik]
die kanzlerin in indien die fünftgrößte
volkswirtschaft der welt zeigt großes
interesse an deutscher technologie
qualitätsprüfung in heimen mit dem neuen
pflege-tüv gibt es nun ein
realistischeres bewertungssystem
täuschung mit folgen falsche narkose
ärztin soll für vier todesfälle in
hessen verantwortlich sein
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
petra gerster guten abend willkommen bei
heute an diesem freitag allerheiligen
norbert lehmann ist auch mit von der
partie sein haben doch von mir was kann
deutschland von indien lernen eine menge
vor allem was die digitalisierung angeht
und was könnte es indien geben know how
für die landwirtschaft zum beispiel mit
gleich einem dutzend
kabinettsmitgliedern ist kanzlerin
merkel nach indien gereist um die
zusammenarbeit mit dem riesigen land zu
intensivieren
in indien der größten demokratie der
welt leben mehr als 1,3 milliarden
menschen
das land ist für deutschland ein
wichtiger handelspartner
im vergangenen jahr wurden waren im wert
von rund 12,5 milliarden euro nach
indien exportiert von dort kam güter für
knapp neun milliarden euro
sharon terlep energy hat die kanzlerin
begleitet wer sich indien erbt muss
bereit sein neue wege zu gehen so kommt
es dass die kanzlerin den ersten
bildtermin heute auf socken absolviert
ehrbezeugung für mahatma gandhi in neu
delhi
andere partner andere sitten der partner
das ist vor allem ya nada in ramot die
indians neuer übervater mit fast schon
brutalem ehrgeiz trimmt modi sein land
derzeit auf mehr
wirtschaftsfreundlichkeit gerne auch mit
hilfe deutschlands im jahr 2022 feiern
wir 75 jahre unabhängigkeit unser ziel
ist es bis dahin ein neues indien zu
bauen
bilaterale partnerschaften wie die mit
deutschland werden und dabei helfen
dieser tatendrang kommt den deutschen
sehr gelegen
es locken 1,3 milliarden menschen und
gigantische marktchancen
auch beim klimaschutz und in
handelsfragen führt an indien kein weg
vorbei kritische fragen wie die
eskalation im kaschmir konflikt
bespricht man da lieber am rande ich
kann und werde heute abend da wird das
auf die tagesordnung kommen sagen wir
setzen uns für deeskalation und für
entspannung 1 sowie im augenblick die
situation für die menschen dort ist ist
sie aber nicht nachhaltig und nicht gut
deutschland und indien konzentrieren
sich auf das was beiden seiten nutzt
partnerschaften für grüne städte
kooperation beim ausbau der eisenbahn
aber auch forschung zu künstlicher
intelligenz und digitalisierung der
landwirtschaft angereist sind die
deutschen mit vielen angeboten abreisen
wollen sie gerne mit mehr
wirtschaftlichen chancen den preis des
aufschwungs konnten merkel und mode
heute gleich mit erleben während sie zur
gedenkzeremonie schritten lag delhi
unter der schlimmsten smog glocke seit
januar nach berlin und damit zur politik
hier in den wochenlangen
koalitionsstreit zur grundrente kommt
offenbar bewegung
die zuständige arbeitsgruppe hatte bis
in die nacht getagt es geht vor allem um
die sogenannte bedürftigkeitsprüfung
also die frage wer soll die grundrente
eigentlich bekommen
fragen wir theo koll in berlin theo die
spd war ja klar gegen die prüfung der
bedürftigkeit die union dafür wie könnte
denn da ein kompromiss aussehen nun die
rentenexperten haben heute schon den
ganzen tag die modelle durchgerechnet
auf die man sich gestern nacht
verständigt hat und die über die die
koalition am montag dann entscheiden
soll nach allem was wir hören konnten
ist die umfassende
bedürftigkeitsprüfungen die ja noch im
koalitionsvertrag steht nicht mehr
vorgesehen also es soll nicht mehr das
vermögen sondern nur noch das laufende
einkommen geprüft werden was viele
unions-abgeordnete hier erzürnt die
union will auf jeden fall bei den
jährlichen gesamtkosten unter zwei
milliarden euro bleiben und sie will
wissen wie olaf scholz das ganze
gegenfinanziert
pd dagegen will erreichen dass
mindestens eineinhalb millionen rentner
ansprüche haben und das vor dem
hintergrund dass allen hier klar ist
dass die grundrente die gegenwärtige
existenzfrage dieser großen koalition
ist danke tieren nach berlin
internetzensur in russland ist das aus
sicht von kritikern inzwischen alltag
heute tritt dort ein gesetz in kraft das
es dem staat ermöglicht den datenverkehr
flächendeckend zu kontrollieren
der kreml begründet die vorschriften mit
sicherheitsgründen
im gefahrenfall müsse der datenfluss
zentral gesteuert werden können aus
moskau christian sind ein freies
internet ohne restriktionen dafür
kämpfen sie hier bei roscoff swoboda an
ngo für die freiheit im internet auf die
gesetzesänderung blicke nation kosslick
und die anderen aktivisten mit sorge vor
allem das inhalte aus dem ausland
geblockt werden könnten
unsere organisation befürchtet dass den
russischen internet-nutzern der zugang
zum westen abgeschaltet wird
das wird zwar nicht im großen stil für
das ganze land umgesetzt werden aber in
einzelnen regionen und so soll die
erweiterung des gesetzes funktionieren
zum einen sollen die filter verbessert
werden um bestimmte inhalte im netz
besser zu blockieren
welche das sind entscheidet eine
staatliche überwachungsbehörde zum
anderen sollen bei hacker angriffen oder
massenprotesten teile des russischen
netzes vom rest des world wide web
abgekoppelt werden können es wurde eine
art russisches intranet entstehen
offiziell heißt es der russische teil
des internets müsse besser kontrolliert
und geschützt werden
von einschränkungen oder dem erschaffen
eines unabhängigen internets wie manche
journalisten behaupten kann keine rede
sein
es geht darum ein verlässliches internet
zu schaffen dass im falle von äußeren
einflüssen wie massiven hacker-angriffen
weiter funktioniert
vor allem junge menschen in russland
haben da ihre zweifel
im märz als die ausmaße des gesetzes
bekannt wurden gingen tausende auf die
straße und bei den protesten im sommer
gegen die kommunalwahl gab es im
moskauer stadtzentrum immer wieder
internet ausfälle
ob hier von offizieller seite geblockt
ist unklar
jetzt suchen nicht nur aktivisten schon
nach alternativen um mögliche sperren zu
umgehen
katastrophale zustände und komplett
überfüllt in den flüchtlingslagern auf
den griechischen inseln wird die lage
immer dramatischer
schauen wir uns die zahlen an mehr als
95.000 menschen kamen insgesamt in
diesem jahr bereits über das mittelmeer
nach europa weniger als 2018 in
griechenland aber steigen die zahlen
etwa 55.000 migranten bis jetzt die
regierung hat nun das asylgesetz
verschärft annette hilsenbeck endlich
weg aus den lagern auf den inseln
monatelang hatten diese migranten dort
vergeblich gewartet wie über ihren
asylantrag entschieden wird so wie es
der eu und türkei takt vorgibt seit
kurzem aber verlegt die griechische
regierung vor allem familien aus
festland denn die camps wie hier auf der
insel lesbos sind heillos überfüllt
immer neue menschen kommen an die
situation dort explosiv kaum zu
bewältigen
griechenlands neue regierung will dem
problem nun mit einem verschärften
asylgesetz begegnen das gestern nacht im
parlament verabschiedet wurde
es soll vor allem die asylverfahren
beschleunigen künftig soll jeder antrag
innerhalb von sechs monaten statt 9
entschieden werden und das ergebnis dem
antragsteller unverzüglich mitgeteilt
werden
abgelehnte antragsteller sollen zügiger
in die türkei zurückgeschickt werden die
bedingungen asyl zu erhalten werden
strenger das kriterium der
posttraumatischen belastungsstörung etwa
schaffen wir als generellen asylgrund ab
flüchtlinge müssen dauerhaft in den
lagern leben müssen dort ständig
erreichbar sein wollen sie nicht die
asylrecht verwirken kritik von der eu
kommissarin für menschenrechte
insbesondere dass die migranten
es werden während des asylverfahrens
dauerhaft in lagern zu leben finde ich
problematisch
die lage auf den inseln will
griechenland weiter entlasten
bis jahresende soll noch 20.000 menschen
aufs festland gebracht werden
die weltklimakonferenz im dezember
findet in madrid statt
eigentlich war santiago de chile
gastgeber wegen der anhaltenden proteste
im land hatte die chilenische regierung
den gipfel allerdings abgesagt
nach bolivien zwei menschen sind bei
gewaltsamen protesten gegen staatschef
morales schon gestorben
in der hauptstadt la paz kam es heute
wieder zu krawallen
die demonstranten werfen morales betrug
vor nachdem der sich zum sieger der
präsidentenwahl vor zwei wochen erklärt
hatte
die regierung hat eine überprüfung des
ergebnisses zwar zugestimmt den
demonstranten geht das aber nicht weit
genug sie fordern morales rücktritt viel
aufmerksamkeit zum ersten arbeitstag die
französin christine lagarde hat heute
ihren neuen job als präsidentin der
europäischen zentralbank angetreten
und wie zur begrüßung trommelten vor
ihrer haustür gruppen wie attac und
freies for future für eine stärkere
sozial ökologische ausrichtung der
geldpolitik isabel de la vega aus
frankfurt am main
die aktivisten von friday future unter
teck sie ziehen vor die ezb mit
forderungen an die neue präsidentin
christine lagarde die zentralbank soll
sich auch im umweltschutz engagieren das
wären 0 muss aufhören anleihen von
rüstungs und ölkonzern zu kaufen
sie muss anleihen kaufen die den
ökologischen und sozialen wandel
befördern
die ezb kauft regelmäßig anleihen
wirtschaftlich starker unternehmen aus
dem euroraum
die umweltaktivisten wollen nun dass
künftig vor allem anleihen ökologisch
ausgerichteter unternehmen so genannte
green bonds gekauft werden
lagarde zeigte sich anfang september
zumindest offen für diese idee den
aufbau von markit bei des kriegs war
momentan gar nicht genügend solcher
grüne
anleihen auf dem markt aber wenn die ezb
signalisiert dass sie an green bonns
interesse hat wird das diesen markt
sicher stärken
der präsident der deutschen bundesbank
aber konnte noch in dieser woche das
sind alles politische fragen gewählte
regierungen und parlamente beantworten
müssen
solche entscheidungen sollten nicht von
notenbanken getroffen werden denn dafür
sind sie demokratisch überhaupt nicht
legitimiert doch neue konflikte kann
sich die ezb kaum leisten denn unter
draghi gab es wegen seiner umstrittenen
geldpolitik viel streit im ezb-rat
experten erhoffen sich von lagarde mehr
diplomatisches geschick und die stärke
wird wohl führung sein also zu sagen ich
habe hier eine versammlung von
verschiedenen meinungen und wir werden
einen diskussionsprozess haben an dessen
ende steht etwas wo alle sagen ja damit
kann ich nicht das kann ich
unterschreiben da mache ich mit und das
ist für christine lagarde könnte so auch
das bild der ezb nach außen verbessern
ob einbruch betrug oder
internetkriminalität viele meinen die
zahl der straftäter steige von jahr zu
jahr
doch den neuesten zahlen des
statistischen bundesamts können das
nicht bestätigen
demnach wurden letztes jahr rund 712.000
300 personen rechtskräftig verurteilt
das waren 0,5 prozent weniger als im
vorjahr 77,3 prozent von ihnen kam mit
einer geldstrafe davon
freiheitsstrafe oder strafrest gab es in
14,4 prozent der fälle die suche nach
einem guten pflegeheim soll einfacher
werden für pflegebedürftige und
angehörige der neue pflege-tüv startet
von heute an bekommen die mehr als
13.000 heime auch besuch von externen
prüfern im nächsten frühjahr sollen dann
erste ergebnisse im internet
veröffentlicht werden die anrufer
berichtet dass ferdinand heim haus in
düsseldorf 79 pflegebedürftige menschen
leben hier
wie gut haben sie es wie professionell
ist die pflege das soll der neue
pflege-tüv besser darstellen denn bisher
wurde nur bewertet was die heime selbst
berichtet haben die dokumentation das
ergebnis fast nur besten
auch dokumentation ist wichtig auf jeden
fall aber dass das das hauptkriterium
für qualität ist das ist jetzt nicht
mehr so sondern der bewohner steht im
vordergrund und das gefällt uns gut
statt der bisherigen pauschalen
gesamtnote gibt es jetzt detaillierte
bewertungen prüfer kommen in die heime
untersuchen mobilität und selbst
versorge der bewohner wie selbstbestimmt
können sie leben die unterstützung bei
krankheit und therapie und auch das
alltagsleben und die möglichkeit zu
sozialen kontakten werden untersucht für
den sozialverband vdk ist der neue
pflege-tüv eine echte chance erneut ist
auf jeden fall herausforderung für die
pflegekräfte und natürlich für auch die
prüfenden institutionen aber meines
erachtens lohnt sich das sehr weh vor
allem natürlich die menschen die sich
eine einrichtung aussuchen müssen haben
anrecht auf die daten die künftigen
kontrollen werden einen tag vorher
angekündigt etwa einmal pro jahr soll
jedes pflegeheim so bewertet werden
auflagen oder strafen für mangelhafte
heine sind im neuen pflege-tüv aber
nicht vorgesehen
die vorwürfe klingen ungeheuerlich im
hessischen fritzlar soll eine heute 48
jährige frau als narkose ärztin
gearbeitet haben ohne dass sie die
entsprechende ausbildung hatte die
staatsanwaltschaft untersucht in diesem
zusammenhang vier todesfälle in der
klinik sie ermittelt auch gegen ärzte
weil sie ihre aufsichtspflicht verletzt
haben sollen
axel conrad fest zusammen
das hospital zum heiligen geist in
fritzlar 173 betten 500 mitarbeiter
davon 40 ärzte eine kollegin sitzt seit
drei tagen im gefängnis
die 48 jährige war von 2015 bis 17 als
assistenzärztin angestellt führte auch
eigenverantwortlich anästhesie ihn also
betäubungen für operationen durch mit
offenbar dramatischen folgen nach einem
eingeholt bei mehreren eingeholten
sachverständigen gutachten gehen wir
davon aus dass sie möglicherweise den
tod von vier menschen zu verantworten
hat mögliche acht weitere patienten
erlitten gesundheitsschäden eine
approbation also die staatliche
zulassung zum arztberuf hatte die vor
nicht noch nicht mal eine für einen
medizinischen beruf erforderliche
fachausbildung so die staatsanwaltschaft
ihre bewerbungsunterlagen gefälscht aber
trotz fehlerhafter arbeit handelten die
vorgesetzten nicht auch gegen sie wird
jetzt ermittelt die hochstapler im op
immer wieder schimmern sich falsche
ärztin krankenhäuser und arztpraxen die
kontrolle der zeugnisse müsse einfacher
werden so patientenschützer denn die
daten liegen oft in mehreren
bundesländern verteilt wir brauchen ein
zentrales archiv für die approbation
sowohl positiv da es geklappt hat da wo
man diese bescheinigung hat aber auch
diejenigen die scheitern und das
transparent abrufbar von jedem
krankenhaus das wäre ein wirklicher ein
richtiger schritt für mehr transparenz
das krankenhaus in fritzlar war nicht
die letzte berufliche station der
betrügerin sie blieb in der region und
arbeitete in einer reha-klinik als
ärztin schon der name sagt es die
katholische kirche gedenkt heute
allerheiligen in fünf bundesländern ist
dieser freitag deshalb feierte begangen
wird der traditionell mit einem
gottesdienst wie hier in münchen
außerdem besuchen viele die gräber von
angehörigen und zünden kerzen an
das totengedenken wird morgen am
allerseelentag fortgesetzt
tja und nun zu der norbert ganz
spannende begegnungen morgen allen voran
die zwischen der heimstarken eintracht
aus frankfurt und dem verunsichert
wirkenden meister aus münchen ex
eintracht trainer kovac muss punkten
sonst dürfte der druck auf den
bayern-coach weiter wachsen
es hakt ein wenig beim deutschen meister
vor vier wochen nach dem glanzvollen 7
zu 2 bei tottenham hotspur in der
champions league noch hoch gelobt laufen
die münchner nach zuletzt durchwachsenen
leistungen vor ihrem gastspiel in
frankfurt ihren eigenen ansprüchen
hinterher
wir müssen dort ganz klar ein anderes
gesicht zeigen gerade in den ersten
minuten weil dort geht es in den ersten
minuten schon auch die post ab niko
kovac steht also unter druck die
bayern-bosse fordern nach zuletzt vielen
gegentoren neben mehr stabilität in der
abwehr auch endlich wieder mehr
spielerischen glanz nach dem mühevollen
2 1 sieg im dfb pokal in bochum wartet
jetzt die eintracht die hessen sind zu
hause ungeschlagen und haben gegen den
rekordmeister einiges vor ich möchte
einfach dass wir auch unser spiel
versuchen durchzuziehen
obwohl wir wissen dass bayer noch hunger
unheimliche qualität hat die nächsten
sieben tage mit spielen gegen frankfurt
piräus und dortmund werden zeigen ob
kubat die hohen ansprüche der bayern
führung erfüllen kann die eintracht
gegen die bayern das top spiel morgen
live zu sehen bei uns im zdf ab 15 uhr
doppeltes aus für deutsche tennisspieler
alexander zverev und jan lennard struff
haben ihre achtelfinal-spiele beim atp
masters in paris verloren
werder unterlag dem kanadier dan sap
walldorf stuft den franzosen jo-wilfried
tsonga
ortswechsel bei olympia die marathon und
g wettbewerber die werden nächstes jahr
nicht in tokio ausgetragen eine
konsequenz aus den schlimmen hitze
erfahrungen bei der leichtathletik wm in
doha da es in der japanischen hauptstadt
im sommer schwül heiß ist findet der
marathon jetzt 800 kilometer weiter
nördlich im kühleren sakko stadt
deutschlands erfolgreichster windsurfer
philip köster hat seinen fünften wm
titel geholt und zwar in der windsurf
königsdisziplin waveriding beim
saisonfinale auf hawaii reichte dem 25
jährigen das erreichen der
viertelfinalrunde zum triumph die
hauptrunde des saisonfinals die war
wegen dauert laut ausgefallen so was
möchte ich auch können schön aus danke
noch bei diesem wetter allerdings
schlecht morgen wird es auch wieder
regnerisch sein später gibt es dann aber
auch sonnige momente wo sagt ihnen
gleich gunther tiersch das war es von
uns für diesen freitag marietta slomka
erwartet sie um 10 zum heute journal
und wir sind morgen abend wieder für sie
da danke für ihr interesse und einen
schönen start ins wochenende
[Musik]
guten abend liebe zuschauer mildes
regenwetter begleitete uns übers
wochenende und deshalb gibt es auch
nachts keinen frost mehr
stattdessen kommt der regen den ja schon
im westen haben der wird durchziehen und
würde uns heute nacht und morgen
letztendlich weiterhin den regen bringen
morgen nachmittag lockert es dann von
westen ein bisschen auf die milde luft
bleibt allerdings ist wird nur wenig
frischer werden ja heute nacht erst
einmal weiterer regen der nach nordosten
weiter zieht besonders auch in der
zweiten nachthälfte kräftiger regen
wieder im südwesten dazu morgen früh
vier bis elf grad etwa also kein frost
mehr zu erwarten und morgen vormittag
regnet es erstmal weiter
die sonne hat kaum eine chance dazu wird
es auch stark windig sein aus west
südwest bis südwind und dann am
nachmittag kann ab und zu mal die sonne
raus kommen der regen lässt nach nur
noch selten gibt es hier und da ein paar
schauer vor allen dingen hier im
südwesten wird es wieder anfangen zu
regnen
ja die temperaturen dann dazu
ungewöhnlich also sind wir lange nicht
mehr gewöhnt 14 bis 18 grad in den
östlichen mittelgebirgen an küsten ist
es ein bisschen frischer und die
aussichten wechselhaft kann man sagen ob
es da sonntag ist oder die neue woche
und bis dienstag könnte es hier im
westen bis zu 20 millimeter wieder
regnen
ich wünsche einen schönen abend und
machen sie es gut